australia toward the middle of 2021 was
in a really difficult position
that a
eventually the virus would find a way in
and b that australia cannot be cut off
from the world indefinitely
such an unprecedented shift in how we
live our lives was made in face of this
pandemic
this story was about the
really difficult transition that
australia needed to pull off in terms of
figuring out how the country was going
to move into the future
in a world where a covet is just a part
of life
so if you think back to february 2020
things changed incredibly fast
we had a confirmation of human to human
transmission in wuhan and then very
quickly it's first case first case first
case in just country after country all
over the world
[Music]
in those critical weeks in australia
there weren't a lot of domestic measures
taken at that point
there was no sign of the panic that was
then really just starting to take hold
in parts of europe and the united states
my name is annika stobart i work
at the gratton institute which is
australia's leading policy think tank i
work in the
health and aged care policy program
a key contributor to
the cases in australia's first wave was
the ruby princess cruise ship people had
been sick and these people didn't
actually end up in isolation they ended
up back into the community it
contributed to a lot of australia's
deaths in that first wave
australia was grappling with the idea of
how to manage the covid pandemic long
term when there weren't any vaccines
available at the time and this is when
this unique idea of the covert zero
approach emerged
we are upgrading the travel ban on
australians to level four
for the entire world the travel advice
to every australian is do not travel
abroad they just closed the borders
completely no one in and and remarkably
as the policy evolved it became clear
that the rule was no one out either you
needed to
actually apply for permission from the
australian government in order to leave
the country on the theory that anyone
leaving would eventually need to come
back in and would thus be a problem for
the australians to keep covet out there
was a lot of debate about whether that
was the right way to do it essentially
there were two courses that the state
minister could take one was to accept
that there would be a lot of community
transmission and therefore have to limbo
in and out of lockdowns to control cases
and the alternative option was to
actually lock down very strictly in a
way that enabled us to get to a point
where there were effectively zero cases
no tourists no business travelers the
few people who were allowed to come in
spent 14 days in hotel quarantine that
was enforced by the military for anyone
who breaches quarantine they face fines
and even jail the penalties ranging from
as much as fifty thousand dollars in wa
and twelve months behind bars eleven
thousand or six months jail in new south
wales like queensland victoria and south
australia all had the power to punish
these were
devastating public health measures for
many people australia is a nation of
immigrants something like 30 of the
population was born abroad
so the inability to travel had huge
costs personally economically for many
millions of people in australia and
outside of it
it was difficult for people most
australians have connections with
communities overseas family friends
many businesses that relied on
international tourists really struggled
but when the country emerged from this
first wave of lockdowns life very
rapidly took on something like it's
pre-covered normalcy you could go to
bars and beaches and restaurants
hamilton even went on stage in sydney
people were going into offices
because we are an island nation we had
the opportunity to actually
have very few cases in the community
until a vaccine would hopefully arrive
in the future
nationally the daily case numbers in
some periods were
in the single or at most the double
digits they could go months without a
single covet death when the u.s for
example was recording literally hundreds
of thousands of deaths
australia might record a death every few
months when australia locked down they
really did they got the level down very
very low we never really locked down as
well or as completely as australia did
so epidemiologically in terms of
protecting
lives these policies were spectacularly
successful in that period
once australia was able to return to
normalcy so much faster than the rest of
the world you had overwhelming public
support and so much so that anyone who
suggested an alternative was was almost
shouted down virgin's ceo has courted
controversy while calling for
australia's international borders to
reopen before
mid-2022 at one point the ceo of virgin
australia said eventually the borders
would have to open and that when they do
people may die
political figures attacked her
vociferously scott morrison said he
could have no truck with comments like
that and it was a real warning to other
public figures in australia that
proposing to live with the virus was
taboo it was just something it was
something you couldn't say became the
third rail of australian politics for a
time
whereas a lot of other countries the uk
canada the u.s moved to lock up vaccine
supplies as soon as they could australia
took a different approach and a somewhat
leisurely one in retrospect there was
this kind of
sense that from the government at least
that things had been sorted that there
was this sense of complacency and that
kind of rolled over into how they
thought about the vaccine roll out which
was a key failure of the government's
response australia didn't make a deal
with pfizer until november 2020
well after other countries had done so
instead australia's strategy was to
focus on the astrazeneca vaccine through
local manufacturing
so when we started the vaccine roll out
with the astrazeneca
we had a couple of fatalities and the
media highlighted zeus fatality and
inadvertently caused panic i think the
government they should have prepared the
public about those real side effects and
at the same time speeded up the visa
mrna based vaccination
a major public education campaign was
underway visit
australia.gov.eu
but it was mainly addressing the
mainstream anglo-saxon background
communities and society and they left
the non-english speaking community
through that public education campaign
and the weakest point for the spread of
that virus
was in people who were not targeted
by a public education campaign
i started in front of my house a covert
assessment and testing clinic
and it was a drive-through i use that
also as an education area where i can
send the right messages to our local
community in the canterbury bankstown
area there was much influence of
cellular science on social media and a
lot of propaganda and conspiracy
theories
[Music]
the public did not have
the right information
about covet pandemic and the virus
itself
and unfortunately that gap needed to be
addressed very soon
a few months ago australia was the envy
of the world winning the war against
covert borders closed but business is
open life relatively normal but as the
highly infectious delta variant takes
hold and our vaccine rollout lags we're
becoming headline news for all the wrong
reasons
delta became the dominant strain and
made its way to australia through
leakages in hotel quarantine and ended
up causing a major outbreak in march
2021 around three percent of australians
had been fully vaccinated whereas the us
and uk were well on their way to
vaccinating the bulk of their
populations a more transmissible variant
in an under-vaccinated population is
kind of a nightmare scenario
so australia had to
panic and that meant these very harsh
lockdowns and it also meant an effort to
step up vaccination as quickly as they
could
it started in australia's most popular
state new south wales and then
eventually spread to victoria
australia's second most populous state
half the country was in lockdowns
schools closed offices closed all of
these freedoms that australians had
taken for granted
for the better part of the last year
were once again taken away all
australians need to accept a hard truth
covert is here to stay delta was just
too transmissible the genie was out of
the bottle australia was never going to
be able to get back to covet zero
australia needed to come to a new
understanding of what living in the
covet age looked like
today it was confirmed and fully agreed
the national plan that pathway that
takes us to the position where we live
with this virus and we live with the
virus where we ultimately start saying
goodbye
to lockdowns once we reach 70
vaccination of the population
this u-turn was politically
controversial there was a lot of
criticism particularly
western australia and queensland the
premiers of those states were not really
on board politics with a battle erupting
over how the states manage the virus
mark mcgowan insists wa's freedoms need
to be maintained
we don't need rash decision making on
the basis of what is occurring in new
south wales
there is an australia outside of new
south wales have a look at the number of
cases in new south wales and
queenslanders don't want to see those
case numbers coming to queensland so
that is why there is a border closure
but there was i think a sense of
resignation that this was the only way
to go this cycle of lockdowns and
freedom lockdowns and freedom had to
stop and that the only way to stop it
was to try a new approach
easing restrictions but only easing
restrictions for people that were double
vaccinated people that were unvaccinated
would essentially continue to have the
lockdown restrictions applied to them
indefinitely 18 months of isolation and
frustration boils to breaking point
so-called freedom rally in melbourne
seeing violence break out between
protesters and police some people felt
like this was imposing on them in a way
that they didn't support
[Music]
there were some protests against vaccine
mandates which got pretty ugly at times
governments did not back down
there was
really very little compromise at any
point
you must be double vaccinated in order
to enter australia with essentially no
exceptions one example of that kind of
spectacular example of that was novak
djokovic arguably the best tennis player
in the world who was kicked out of
australia because he had entered without
being double vaccinated to play in the
australian open djokovic had his visa
revoked after being held at melbourne
airport for several hours there should
be no special rules for novak djokovic
at all that is an example of just how
serious the australian government is
going to take the vaccination issue
once vaccination rates in australia
reached high levels
this triggered different levels of
liberalization we saw an end to lockdown
measures things like restaurants and
nightclubs reopened in november the
borders reopened in some respects the
first flight from los angeles today was
qf-12 under the new conditions there was
a real party mood down here at sydney
airport's arrivals terminal omicron has
come in and has arrived with the same
full force that it did elsewhere but
high vaccination rates have done the job
of preventing large numbers of deaths
so i don't think there are there are
many strong arguments against the policy
mix that australia pursued it saved an
incredible number of lives economically
uh it's a little less clear if you look
at 2020 gdp performance across major
economies australia was more or less
flat and part of that was simply being
able to get back to normal resuming
normal life for most people most of the
time
was a a bigger economic positive than
closing the borders was an economic
negative
[Music]
[Music]
you